hi my name is Rotem aya
I'm the tech lead for the Android
developer relations team at Google and
I'm here to dig beneath the delicious
chocolate shell of the latest favor of
Android and into the wife of biscuity
goodness at the center of the new
developer features KitKat may only
represent a point one increase in
version number but it turns out that a
small bump can still include a lot of
new features where the defining
characteristic of jellybean was buttery
smoothness KitKat is all about memory
optimization Android 4.4 is designed to
run just as smoothly on a much broader
range of devices including those with as
little as 512 mix of RAM for developers
that means a selection of new api's and
tools to help us ensure that our apps
are as memory efficient as the platform
you can start by checking if your app is
running on a memory constrained device
using the new is low RAM device call on
the activity manager based on the result
you might choose to modify or even
disable features with significant memory
implications to ensure your app provides
a great user experience on devices with
memory limits similar to those featured
black guy Pearce's character in memento
of course disabling features is always a
last resort so check out this guide for
tips on how you can optimize your apps
memory usage without having to sacrifice
functionality but before you can start
improving your apps memory efficiency
you need to first understand how you're
using memory in the first place the new
product stats tool helps you analyze
memory resources providing a data about
apps execution durations and memory use
you can access proc stats from the adb
tool by calling adb shell dumps S proc
stats if command lines make you nervous
fear not Android 4.4 also includes a new
developer option that helps you analyze
your apps memory profile on any Android
4.4 device or emulator through the
process stats developer options screen
below the system memory summary there's
a list of blue bars indicating the
relative computed memory load of each
apps process and the relative percentage
of time each has spent in the background
selecting an app displays a summary of
the memory
and the percentage of the collection
interval that this particular app has
been running for as well as the average
and maximum RAM usage it's not all about
memory efficiency that a KitKat also
includes some new ways to build
beautiful apps starting with some
updates to the Android design guide
designed to help you create striking
innovative and distinctive apps that
offer users a magical experience for
more details check out tomorrow's
episode of Android design in action in
terms of API is there support for a more
immersive full-screen experience a new
transition framework for animating
scenes closed captioning support and a
new tool for high fidelity screen
recording the new full-screen immersive
mode lets you create full bleed you
wires that reach from edge to edge
hiding all system UI including the
status and navigation bars and allows
your app to respond to touch events from
areas that would otherwise be occupied
by the system bars it's a great solution
for rich visual content such as photos
videos maps books and games you can
enable this new mode using two new
mutually exclusive system UI flags
immersive and immersive sticky this code
shows how to toggle between an immersive
full-screen experience within your app
using the immersive flag alternatively
you can utilize the immersive sticky
flag to create a persistent immersive
experience that will automatically
rehire the system bars after a short
delay or if the user interacts with the
middle of the screen you can learn more
about the new immersive modes including
the best practices for using each
alternative in Roman Nurik immersive
mode dev byte to make it easier to
create high quality animations in your
app Android 4.4 also introduces a new
transitions framework for animating
between scenes now it's pretty common to
use animations to help users understand
their progress through UI states where
each state can expose different actions
the new transitions framework helps you
define these scenes typically view
hierarchies like these and the
transitions which define how to animate
the transformations between scenes when
the user enters or exit them you can use
one of several predefined transition
types based on specific properties like
layout balance or visibility or use the
auto transition type to automatically
fade move and resize views during a
scene change
you can also define custom transitions
that animate the properties that matter
most to your Apple even plug-in your own
animation styles for more details check
out the transitions dev byte from our
master of animation chet haase in an
effort to make your apps more accessible
Android 4.4 includes system-wide
preferences for closed captioning
users can now set global captioning
preferences and apps that use video can
use those settings to adjust how they
present closed captions by using the new
captioning manager apps that use video
view can simply pass a captioning stream
in web VTT format along with the video
stream for rendering and the system will
handle the display of the captions
according to those user preferences for
more details check out this devbyte by
alan beaver at the engineer who
implemented it all if you've ever tried
to record a demo of your app by holding
a video camera
very steady you'll appreciate the new
screen recording tool that lets you
capture video as you use the device and
store it as an mp4 you can record at any
device supported resolution and bitrate
and the output retains the aspect ratio
of the display you can access screen
recording through the ADB tool calling
adb shell screen record or through the
DDMS panel in eclipse or Android studio
KitKat also includes a couple of
significant new storage API changes with
a new storage access framework and a
fully supported SMS content provider the
new storage access framework makes it
easy for users to browse and open
documents images and other files across
all of the available local and
cloud-based document storage providers
if you develop an app that manages files
or users documents you can integrate
with the storage access framework using
the create document or open document
intents and the system will display the
standard UI including content from all
the available document providers if you
want to add a storage provider you
implement a new documents provider
overriding these four methods will let
you manage the browsing reading and
writing of any local or remote data that
can be represented as files then you
just need to add the documents provider
and MANET manifest intent filter and
request permission to manage documents
this process will register your provider
with the storage access framework and
make it available to the standard UI
then whenever your app is installed any
that uses this framework to view or
select files will provide access to your
content
our very own Lisa Raye has created dev
bytes for both provider and consumer
users of the storage access framework so
check them out for more details
now if you've been using undocumented
methods to provide an MS an SMS based
app now is an excellent opportunity to
familiarize yourself with the official
API as for SMS handling that primarily
involves a newly documented SMS content
provider but also introduces new
semantics for receiving messages and
writing to the provider when a message
is received the system routes it
directly to the users default messaging
app using the SMS deliver intent while
other apps can continue to listen for
incoming messages using the SMS received
intent only the default app is able to
write new messages to the SMS provider
though other apps can continue to read
from it apps that aren't the current
default can also continue to send
messages here the system will write
those outgoing messages to the provider
on your behalf so the users can still
see them in their default app for more
details check out Adams dev byte
also included in android 4.4 are a
number of additions to help your app
interact with the real world including
new Bluetooth profiles for Bluetooth hid
/ GATT which provides apps with a low
latency link for low-power peripheral
devices like mouse mice joysticks and
keyboards and Bluetooth map for nearby
device message exchange there's also new
platform support for built-in IR
blasters with a new API that lets you
check whether the device has an infrared
emitter query its carrier frequencies
and then send infrared signals there's
also support for host card emulation hce
add support for secure NFC based
transactions for things like payments
loyalty programs card access and transit
passes by allowing your app to emulate
an NFC smart card though without
requiring a provisioned secure element
it also supports a new reader mode to
have your app act as a reader for HTE
cards and other NFC based transactions
Android HCE
emulates ISO seven eight 16-bit smart
cards using the ISO 14 for 3-4 protocol
for transmission along with the
application identifiers as defined in
ISO 78 16-4 as the basis for routing
transaction
to the correct Android applications
there's also native platform support for
printing along with api's for managing
printing over Wi-Fi or cloud hosted
services such as Google Cloud Print you
can use these new api's to add printing
capabilities for nearly any type of
content from local images and documents
to network data or anything that you can
render to a canvas and reduces PDF as
its primary file format for printing so
it's best practice to use the helper
classes to print bitmaps or to generate
a properly paginate at PDF version of
your content for convenience the
printing API provides native and webview
help us to let you create PDFs using
standard Android drawing AP is if your
app knows how to draw the content it can
create a PDF for printing it Nazmul
Idris summarizes the best practices for
getting started with printing on Android
in this deaf-blind Kitcat also
introduces new ways to improve the power
use profile of device sensors starting
with cents of batching a new
optimization that delivers sensor
results in batches rather than as they
are detected this lets the application
processor stay in a low-power state
until each batch is delivered you can
define the interval at which you receive
batches or request immediate delivery of
events between batch cycles there's also
two new composite sensors step detection
and step counting both of which were
implemented within hardware to help
minimize the Associated power
consumption now that's just a small
taste of the new API is available
there's also a completely new
implementation of webview based on
Google chromium that offers the latest
in standard support performance and keep
compatibility and most of the html5
features available in Chrome for Android
version 30 plus an updated JavaScript v8
engine there's also a range of new API
eyes to better support RTL locales
including drawable mirroring and pseudo
locales declaring a drawable as Auto
Mirabal will allow the system to flip it
automatically for users using an RTL
locale preventing you from having to
duplicate your assets Android now also
includes an RTL pseudo locale as a new
developer option the pseudo locale
switches the device to an RTO layout for
all locales and displays text in the
current language this can help you find
layout issues across your app with
having to display the app in an RTL
language that you may not be able to
read there's also good news for fans of
high performance computation with
performance improvements to render
script and the new ability to take
advantage of render script directly from
your native code and you C++ API in the
NDK lets you access the same render
script functionality available through
the framework api's including script
intrinsics and custom kernels last but
by no means least is a series of
security enhancements including an
update to Android's SELinux
configuration changing from permissive
to enforcing and improved cryptographic
algorithms elliptic curve digital
signature algorithm support has been
added to the keystore provider and the
script key derivation function is now
implemented to protect the cryptographic
keys used for full disk encryption in
entirely related news there is a new
device in town with the launch of the
Nexus 5 check out Google Play for all
the details and grab one for yourself
purely for development purposes of
course the Android 4.4 SDK is now
available for your downloading and code
updating pleasure using the SDK manager
and you can get more details on all of
the new API s features best practice in
every other change at
developers.google.com